now you've got these two evil creatures
here the Fox and the cat I think this
one's based on one of the Marx Brothers
actually Harpo Marx who I believe never
said anything but be that as it may
there are these near do well characters
on the Fox in particular now Fox is a
standard trickster animal right it's a
it's it's it's it's a classic animal
maybe because it's it's good at hiding
and it's good at hunting I don't know
exactly why but it's and coyotes are
like that too
their classic trickster animals he's
kind of like wily coyote in fact you
know the Warner Brothers character whose
genius at large and of course whose
arrogance continually gets him walloped
and this character has a lot of features
like that but he he feigns being a an
English gentleman of like the 1890s and
pretends to be educated and and he has a
kind of high blown way of talking and
he's a fraud through and through and
he's got he's got this you know sidekick
who is barely there at all and he
doesn't treat him that well but he's got
someone to lord it over so that keeps
his dominance hierarchy thing going well
and the fact that he's like a
second-rate companion while he never
really notices that although he'll treat
him contemptuously whenever he gets a
chance so anyways they're walking down
the street and the Fox is bragging away
about some crooked thing that he's done
and how he pulled the wool over
someone's eyes and he confuses that with
wisdom and intelligence and one of the
things that you see this is worth
knowing too because if you're preyed
upon by a psychopath which you will be
to some degree at some point in your
life the psychopath who will be
narcissistic will presume that you're
stupid and and that you deserve to be
taken advantage of because you're not
even stupid so it's actually a good
thing that he's doing it and he is proof
for and I'm saying he because there are
more male Psychopaths the the proof that
your stupid naive is that he can take
advantage of you and so like if you were
wiser you'd be you know you'd know his
tricks and then it wouldn't
morally necessary for him to show you
just exactly who knows what about what
and so the psychopath will use his
ability to to fool you as proof of his
own grandiose grandiose omnipotence
omniscience and narcissism and the
problem with that is that you you can be
fooled by a psychopath and virtually
anybody can so that Robert hare for
example who studied Psychopaths for a
long time and interviewed a lot of them
like hundreds of them and videotaped
many of the interviews he said when he
was talking to the psychopath he always
believed what they were saying and then
he watched the video afterwards and see
where the conversation went off the
rails but you know the proclivity to be
polite in a conversation is very strong
and if you're polite you don't object to
the way that the person unfolds their
strategy you know and Psychopaths are
pretty good at figuring out how to
manipulate obviously how to manipulate
people and the probability that you will
be immune to that is extraordinarily low
go watch Paul Bernardo being interviewed
by policeman on on the YouTube that's
bloody it that's enlightening man Paul
Bernardo he's like the CEO of a meeting
in that video you know he gives the cops
hell it gives the lawyers hell he
protests his innocence he basically
tells them that they're rude and
untrustworthy because they don't trust
him
because he did a few little things 17
years ago and he gets away with it a few
little things right I mean he killed a
bunch of people including the sister of
his girlfriend at the time and you know
he was a repeat sexual offender and
murderer it's like but he basically goes
well you know that's a long time ago
it's like we're past that aren't we I
mean I'm having a discussion with you
I'm trying to solve help you solve some
crimes which by the way I committed but
we won't bring that up you know and
you're you're accusing me of being a
liar like you're not playing fair what's
up with you and then when the answer he
looks at his fingernails which is like
that's a lovely little manipulative
thing because it basically means
whatever happens to be under my
fingernail at the moment is much higher
priority than listening to your foolish
story and you watch you'll see people do
that to you and then you get a little
insight into what they're up to
he's very good at that and so or he
looks so
I already just looks at his hands or he
looks out the window immediately
dismissive in his nonverbal behavior
well it's brilliant that the courts were
forced to release that by the way but
look it up Paul Bernardo on YouTube Wow
it's just mind-boggling it's he's so
good at what he does and he's
good-looking and he's charismatic and
you know he can really pull it off and
you can't tell what's happening with the
cops and the lawyers whether they're
just letting him play his routine to get
some information from him or whether
he's actually setting them back on his
heels and I suspect it's a bit of both
but it's masterful performance if you
didn't know who he was and you were
watching it without the audio you'd
think he's the CEO of some company given
his employees hell for not being up to
scratch that's all his body language his
eye contact everything just speaks that
it's amazing